et
[Musique]
la guerre contre gênes est déclarée les
shadoks ont résolu de l'exterminer les
attaques aériennes ont échoué les
vaillants shadow claude vont ils sauver
la situation
les shadoks avaient formé un corps
spécial de cosmonautes ont aussi jugé
c'était un corps d'élite et j'oublie un
entraînement excessivement intensifs
[Musique]
il n'avait pas de fuser mais ce n'était
pas important parce que la terre est en
dessous vous remarquerez que ce n'était
pas comme nos cosmonautes de maintenant
des cosmonautes pour monter mais des
cosmonautes pour descendre on n'avait
qu'à les laisser tomber
c'était très économique est
techniquement très intéressant pour les
cosmonautes
ça a été un peu mois il fallait qu'il
soit présent durci l'entraînement
commencez donc par un an durcissement
systématique à la machine a endurci
les shadoks note d'ailleurs n'avait
aucun intérêt à revenir parce que pour
l'hérault dans la vie civile il aurait
fallu les pinces et à la machine à
attendrir et c'était 100 fois pire venez
tout de suite le maniement tard chazot
coup aviv ue - larmes total on dit gg
c'était l'ex permis nateur qui clouerait
littéralement l'ennemi sur place comme
il n'avait pas de gégène sous la main
des shadoks volontaires étaient déguisés
en gêne pour que les autres puissent
s'entraîner en toute sécurité
il y avait de plusieurs sortes d'abord
l'exterminateur à main on avait aussi
l'exterminateur automatique
on allait enfin l'exterminateur à
retardement de loin le plus dangereux
les exterminateurs shadow que vous voyez
là sont seulement des exterminateurs
d'entraînement les exterminateurs de
guerre les vrais était beaucoup plus
petit beaucoup plus maniable et beaucoup
plus redoutable gégène m'en parlent
parfaitement tendu aussi armés jusqu'aux
dents
c'est ainsi que la première expédition
tijen descendit de la lune et les
voyants passaient les shadoks dans leurs
coeurs sont et renaître l'espoir de
revoir bientôt la tête
[Musique]
et